it's time for the launching horoscope a
television journal of the important
issues of the hour thought so you every
Monday Wednesday and Friday a
presentation of the lawn gene which nor
what's company maker of launching the
world's most honored watch and wit nor
distinguished companion to the world
honored lon gene good evening this is
David Ross may I introduce our
co-editors for this edition of the lawn
gene chroma scope mister william
bradford huie and mr. carl hess press
editor of newsweek magazine our
distinguished guest for this evening is
mr. george a sloan chairman of the
United States Council of the
International Chamber of Commerce mr.
Sloan it's a pleasure to have you with
us again on the corona scope our viewers
will remember that you're the man who
comes on and tells us how to increase
world trade and how perhaps we can
promote world peace through World Trade
the night sir we have a new
administration coming up in Washington
and I'm sure that our viewers would be
interested in your ideas about what is
likely to happen under this new
administration now first sir a great
deal has been said recently about a
policy of trade not aid a policy whereby
we might cut down some of our foreign
aid if we traded more now just what is
the meaning of that that slogan sir well
mr. urea the meaning of the slogan is
that we would be better off in the free
world would be better off if we could
have more World Trade and less charity
from America perhaps it would be better
if we would rephrase that phrase and
and call it two-way trade not one way
aid in other words we don't have there's
plenty of demand for what we have to
sell but the trouble is the problem is
how to get more dollars abroad isn't it
that's that's cool does that mean how to
get more dollars abroad so more
purchases can be made from us that would
be one resulting benefit site me well
does this impinge upon the aid programs
our shipping of dollars broad well of
course I think we've reached the point
mr. Hess where we can't go on certainly
indefinitely with these huge
appropriations for foreign aid and
unfortunately the European countries
have reached the state of mind where
they don't what continued charity they
would much prefer to trade with us you
know this expression mr. he referred to
came from our a butler the Chancellor of
Exchequer in Great Britain in the spring
he was the one who started this trade
not aid idea and it spread all over
Europe and now it's back in this country
we hear it only this week now principal
the principal problem is how we can
purchase more goods that are
manufactured abroad is absolutely and I
and and you have I believe the National
Association of Manufacturers has
endorsed this trade not aid now it
doesn't it seem strange that big
businesses big American businesses like
General Motors for instance should
encourage American people to buy more
foreign manufactured goods well I don't
know that General Motors has come out
and advocate them to buy more foreign
cars but I think it's fair to say and
that I'm sure is what you mean that the
automobile industry in general favors
two-way trade but what will be the
effect of two-way trade trade on these
industries well first of all let me say
that the effective two-way trade would
be beneficial to our entire economy and
it would mean lower costs for the
American public of many
things that can buy it would do after
all we would still compete with these
foreign producers and no one is
advocating that we remove all trade
barriers that we go to free trade what
we're advocating is that there should be
a scientific approach to this whole
problem and there be a gradual gradual
lowering of these trade barriers so now
the new administration accomplished this
oh well there are a number of things
that must be done I am very hopeful that
in the early days of the new
administration you will see General
Eisenhower insist on consolidating some
10 or 12 emergency foreign economic
agencies into one group and preferably
under one roof and under one department
and cabinet status and what department
would you like to see it consolidated I
would much prefer to see it to
consolidated under the united states
department of commerce you mean that
would put a man like mr. stassen out of
a job oh not at all I of course I have
the highest respect for governor stassen
mutual security has been a very very
important activity in in the present
administration it can't be stopped
overnight but I should hope that
Governor stassen would begin to do a
good liquidating job when I'm still
arise sir our our viewers are interested
in several things number one some of
them may be interested in lower taxes
they want to see this new administration
cut taxes in this country now can
foreign trade help us to cut taxes mr.
here a I don't know of any other way
that we can affect a substantial
reduction in taxes in the immediate
years ahead without reducing these huge
appropriations for foreign aid and I
don't know how how we can do that unless
we are going to begin to take more
products from these countries unless we
accept more info or nowadays week this
these products coming into this
country we have to reduce our tariffs
don't we in order for those more
products to come into our country well
that would be part of the program we
also have to have less restrictions in
the way of import quotas but the
Republican Party has always stood in the
public mind for high tariffs now do you
mean to say that you expect a Republican
administration to start going back to
mr. hulls reciprocal trade and start
cutting tariffs mr. Hewitt let me say
this I've discussed these problems at
great length with General Eisenhower in
Europe last winner and last May he has a
wonderful grasp of these problems and I
believe that he goes along with the
suggestions made here this evening and
the American public after all is just
elect just elected General Eisenhower
and I should hope that the American
public would help him see that his
program is supported by the Congress it
isn't there some public fear of
unemployment as a result of this this
sort of lowering of tariffs well perhaps
and I think that's due to lack of
education on that part I don't think
that we should stop with education when
some particular issue is up before the
tariff commission or before a
congressional committee where we go up
or wear a department of government goes
up on the hill will say and argues
against a particular lobbying group I
think there must be continuing education
in America well I are you in favor for
instance sir of Japan selling more
manufactured products in the United
States I think we must accept more
Japanese products in the United States
after all Japan today is the Rock of
Gibraltar for the United States in the
Pacific Japan can't look to China for
its markets anymore Japan has to live
and a country can't be of much help to
us in the rest of the free world unless
they have a sound it can't
me and Japan has to trade to live well
now what about this our viewers though
who may be afraid of losing their jobs
because of Japanese products coming into
our country is any ground for such fear
mr. Yuri I don't know of a single
instance where a nation has suffered by
increased imports but we could watch
that we could watch it very carefully
let's gradually reduce these towers
let's gradually remove their time you're
not for unrestricted free what is the
attitude in Europe toward this idea
latitude in Europe and as I tried to
make clear in the beginning they want to
trade with us they don't want more of
this economic aid which they call
charity what this would this call upon
them to impose new restrictions upon
their economy oh I see what you mean if
you I don't think we can succeed in this
great effort to remove barriers
throughout the free world and getting
World Trade started without cooperation
on their part I think that what we're
suggesting here is is just an example of
what must happen all over the free world
and especially in Western Europe and I
think they're prepared to move I think
they'll follow our leadership what a
concrete indications are there there
well there's very definite feeling in
Western Europe today that they should
move toward the free convertibility of
currencies they can't do it until they
get their economies in better shape it's
a matter of wheels within wheels one way
to get their economy in better shape is
to sell more for american dollars I have
great hopes that we're going to action
have free convertibility of currencies
within the next year what about peace
sir do you think that that trade such as
you're advocating will contribute to to
the movement toward peace in the world I
can't think of anything that would
contribute more to the peace of the
world mr. Hugh a we can't have peace we
can't have security until we have strong
economies among our when I is a final
question sir those of our viewers who
should share your views who want to
promote World Trade what can they do now
to help our government actually
encourage more imports in the United
States well I think the public is going
to be very keenly alive to what General
Eisenhower president-elect Eisenhower's
going to recommend as soon as he takes
office and unless I'm mistaken he's
going to move in these directions and
when the public sees him move in these
directions the public which supported it
I think will support him before Congress
our Congress will will probably oppose
or some segments of Congress will oppose
the lowering of tariffs on certain
products Oh obviously that is true but I
don't think that the Congress I don't
think that a sufficient number of
congressmen will oppose such a move if
they if they know the public wants it
done Congress after all is very
sensitive but I feeling well thank you
very much for being with us ladies issue
the opinions you've heard our speakers
expressed tonight are entirely their own
the editorial board for this edition of
the lawn gene Cronus coke was mister
william bradford huie and mr. Carl hess
our distinguished guest was mr. George a
sloan chairman of the United States
Council of the International Chamber of
Commerce